okay all right here's the first story
Pelosi said she wanted to punch Trump as
January 6 Riot began video shows I want
you to listen to that headline real
quick as January 6th Riot began because
we're going to use the language the
mainstream media to paint a picture for
you so the riot is beginning okay what
else did Nancy Pelosi say I hope he
comes I want to punch him out Pelosi
says in response this is my moment I
have been waiting for this for
trespassing on the capitol grounds I
want to punch him out and I'm going to
go to jail and I'm going to be happy
says Nancy Pelosi
so let's just uh
hold on there a minute what does it mean
when someone says this is my moment I've
been waiting for this it means you knew
that it was coming it also implies you
wanted it to happen you're like this is
the moment I've been waiting for like my
it sounds like you it's something you
want to happen or she's an opportunist
and this was the perfect time for her to
pretend like she's some heroic figure in
politics yeah but but when she said for
trespassing on the capitol grounds and
the Washington Post says as Riot began
that implies she wanted the riot she
wanted to exploit it and she had a film
crew with her ready to go as it was
happening like I just I'm sorry you
piece this together and it's a woman
saying here's my camera crew filming me
this is what I've been waiting for for
the trespassing
it sounds like she knew it was gonna
happen yeah if she wants to go to jail
why can't she just go to jail Nancy
Pelosi yeah she could that's true very
true it's because her husband always
drives yeah yeah she wasn't with him
when he crashed though was she no no no
no no but you know another good point
too is if she wants to go to jail why
doesn't she just buy the stocks instead
of having her husband yeah right yeah
well and it was such like Insider Trader
Behavior to have like her kid there
filming not somebody else or whatever
just like her kid because imagine all
the other great footage that her child
is gonna have because obviously they
knew that there was something going to
be happening that day for her to have
premeditatedly have her child come in to
film all of this so I'm sure her kid's
going to have a great documentary it's
going to put her on a map about all the
footage she has That's Unique for you
know this terrible event that happened
on the you know the day yeah I have a
feeling that they're going to say
something like she was just their phone
it's no big deal like people are there
filming this stuff all the time time you
know whatever
oh yeah we gotta stay close to our mics
oh yeah just pull it up a little bit
yeah right you're gonna look right at it
right up in it there you go well love it
ladies Luke what a violent unhinged
human being and she's known for getting
Insider tips so uh what's going on here
of course you know a lot of people will
have their theories here but uh a lot of
people did see a lot of trouble coming
our way on January 6th and for some
reason they got rid of security and
limited the amount of people that would
respond to a big emergency that they saw
coming there was even Facebook pages and
Facebook events literally detailing hey
there's going to be you know rallies and
people attempting to go into the capital
on January 6th so the intelligence
agencies the government agencies on you
it was coming Nancy Pelosi the queen of
insider trading didn't see this coming
no she did she said she was waiting for
it that's the official story is that she
didn't see this coming well that's you
know it's contradicted by her own
statements the moment I've been waiting
this is my moment I've been waiting for
this for trespassing on the capitol
grounds
maybe she did like I'm sorry that's her
saying she knew it was gonna happen well
maybe they're responsible for Designing
the entire day right I mean the
conspiracy theory is like why why
weren't there police there were very few
why did police open the doors AOC said
this and you know I'm sorry I have to
call out what an unhinged conspiracy
theorist can you believe her Alexandria
ocasio-cortez coming out and saying that
police were helping the rioters well we
know that's true but
I I don't know so I gotta experience a
theorist I gotta ask wasn't Nancy Pelosi
the one who wanted
crew served equipment machine gun was it
before or after I can't remember after
was it after afterwards she called for
uh machine gun turrets to be installed
at the U.S Capitol
it was before wasn't it I thought I
believe it was afterwards I might be
wrong but we could look that up right
now and find out why can't all the other
governments that we've taken over they
all had them at their fortresses so
actually knew the fence was coming yeah
yeah it's uh it's kind of interesting to
see it's almost like I feel like you're
trying to trying to allude to like the
40 chess moves that she could be making
in the background we have no idea what
could be happening it was afterwards
when they sent the National Guard to
sleep inside of the capital if you
remember that chance and she was on
record saying afterwards like we need
machine gun turrets here in order to
protect everyone and to mow down those
crazy grandmamas maybe she had just
invested in a machine gun company
the seed
well does she have no no this was before
uh probably yeah so I have the story
from CNS acting DHS Deputy deputy
secretary Pelosi wanted crew manned
machine guns in Washington that was
rejected I think uh what they were
saying is that because of the BLM riots
in in 2020 because of the the 529
Insurrection Pelosi was like okay with
this thing coming up we need you know
crew served machine guns could you just
imagine if like Pelosi and the Democrats
actually got those things mounted and
they're like on swivels and they're like
just like mowing people that like the
funny thing about this story is that
Pelosi doesn't realize bullets keep
going
so just imagine the foundation the first
floor of every building just peppered
with what kind of bolts do these someone
someone super chatted us like 303 or
something that said I don't know what
kind of bolts they would use for these
you know 50 cal Maybe
50 cal fully auto no that's like
anti-material rounds but yeah here's the
story you know Nancy Pelosi wanted
machine guns she would quickly rewrite
that event it would be a massacre and uh
it would somehow turn into her being the
hero again
on my head but is she the the most
corrupt politician hmm
yeah okay yeah she's definitely up there
like I I feel like she's
non-partisan she's always going to be in
politics uh even after her uh her flesh
body dies
didn't it already happen so like yeah
after she ages out we'll call it she's
80. the the shadow monster that
possesses the reanimated corpse will
emerge and then possess a new member of
Congress okay yeah and that's how it
plays out uh I actually I have some
Insider information oh
that uh leads some individuals to
believe Pelosi expects not to be in
Congress this this coming term really
yeah I can't say much more than that
because the the sources are still
currently working on the story but based
on internal goings on I can say it's
seeming like she doesn't think she'll be
in office does she think she's going to
retire or is she going to depart voted
out mortal coil she's gonna be voted out
yeah I think she's I think she's well
they're not voting out retiring I'm
sorry I'm sorry I think okay uh of the
speakership she's not going to get the
speakership she may run she'll probably
win but I think she might retire
actually because that's the only way you
get someone like Pelosi out she chooses
to leave you know I'm almost terrified
to see who is going to replace her
because I don't know in in San Francisco
or Speaker of the House who's going to
be the speaker of the house yeah exactly
they're probably assassinate Putin and
then put her in she's probably going to
run Russia as well
you know it'll be really cool though it
would be cool just like I want you to
imagine that right now you fall asleep
and you wake up and it's 10 years later
and you don't know why you're doing a
coma and you turn the TV on and there's
cyber Pelosi with like machine parts on
her face and then she's looking into the
camera with like one glowing red camera
aren't you like hello people oh wow I am
hardly reclaiming Russia for everyone
that's a good Nancy Pelosi yeah that's
good right this is his best impression
my biggest fear was that I would die
before her yeah
it'd just be something on my deathbed
like oh no what did I do wrong she's
still I mean she's gonna be a hundred no
I think she might be retiring
I think she might be I don't know though
I think even if who who's going to who
could replace her that would be better
considering the district it's San
Francisco there's there's poop
everywhere and the people are just
walking around looking at it and it's so
bad they created a poop Department I I
just don't see Improvement you know you
know in South Park there was a big
campaign for turd sandwich so you know
it might not be that far off to see you
know an actual turd sandwich be voted on
the election that I would vote for it we
might actually get to that point where
people just like they're fed up yeah and
they're like the Republican candidates a
ham sandwich and they're like whatever
sounds great it's better than the
Democrat I mean you look at look at John
fetterman the dude is is he has brain
damage and I mean that in the literal
sense I'm not trying to be disrespectful
he actually had a stroke and now he
cannot process sounds he doesn't know
what people are saying to him well what
better indicator that it's your time to
shine than like the Joe Biden presidency
if you're incompetent please step up to
the plate this is your time well also if
she if she doesn't have a lot of power
and she's not going to be the majority
leader or if she's going to be my the
minority leader if Republicans take the
house she's probably going to be like ah
there's not enough information for me to
get here to make more money off of this
she's 81 years old she's been in in the
house for 33 years that's a lot of time
in in government that's a lot of
information that you could squeeze for
your own personal benefit there's a
limit to anything so she's like you're
not going to Don Lemon me and put me on
a Morning Show I'm not taking any down
man can you just imagine The View
with her oh gosh you have you know
Whoopi Goldberg asked her a question
well I picked a lot of problem is it's
just a problem for this country I
disagree I think that the view is the
best place for Nancy to retire to I can
imagine she would fit right in she's got
the right look she's got the right
following and she has all the
connections I love this idea she'd fire
the existing crew and be like my
daughter and yeah
my uh one of my favorite Family Guy
jokes is they're watching The View and
it's all of the women and they're
sitting there and they're going on
and they're all blocking each other and
then all of a sudden one of the women
goes like she sits up and there's an egg
on the couch but then just to butter
this joke perfectly the camera Zooms in
on the egg and then you hear Little
Women barking even more and I'm like
that was just great like I get the joke
that they're clucking but then to show
the egg and zoom in on it and his
Masterpiece I don't think that's fair
because the view doesn't actually
produce anything eggs are valuable you
can eat them the view gives us nothing
nothing that's true I'm not sure yeah
you know chickens chickens have have
actually you know look I think the view
is detrimental yeah so this this low low
information show it was it was
fascinating I saw I saw a clip where
apparently uh Whoopi Goldberg was
talking to the her co-star from Sister
Act and the show is such low information
that the actress didn't even know they
were doing another one Whoopi Goldberg
was like yeah we're getting our script
at the end of the month and she's like
huh what I was like wow that's really
impressive like you're actually I don't
maybe maybe she's not in the movie but
I'm like you you were in the first two
and you don't even know that's how low
information the view is the people who
are involved in the movie don't even
know what's happening I hate brilliant
of you I hate the view because it it
convinces women that they're watching
what they're actually doing is just
demoing how to gang up on conservatives
yeah I mean yeah but that's all the show
is yeah I love how they just they have
these weird token conservatives that
aren't really conservative that just
agree with like I'm a conservative but
you know what I agree Joe Biden is great
and it's like who were these people
they're they're the feminine version of
the Lincoln project you know those
balling guys look like they're a Viagra
commercial and Rogaine commercial these
are those ladies don't the Lincoln
project like kids yeah they're sure too
a little too much children wasn't that
like what was up with that that was like
a thing where like
they were sending gross messages to
underage boys I think oh it was yeah are
they mad at Trump because Trump was was
ragging on pitos I think I think that's
probably it I remember when Trump was
doing that debate and they asked him
about q and like pizza gate stuff and
then Trump was like well you know they
think I'm you know I'm fighting against
it so you know what's wrong with that
that's probably why the Lincoln project
got mad not the conspiracy theory is
real but that it was like it was a real
insult to the pedo community so Lincoln
project naturally was just offended most
affected thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there